Anything that can be changed to prevent long-lasting two weeks of ear discomfort and popping after
hyperbaric chamber. Oh, okay. So a downside of hyperbaric chamber is that you're not open
and you're used station tubes. Okay, you're used station tubes. If you want to look at it, it's EU
S-T-A-T-I-A-N tubes are tubes that run from your middle ear down to the back of your throat.
So they are a soft vascular like tube, so they're not carrying blood. But it's a tube that
regulates your ear pressure in your middle ear. So if you go up at an airplane and your ears won't
pop, you have a blockage of your used station tube. When you go up at an airplane and your ears do
pop, it's because that popping noise is actually the vascular, you know, it's a soft tube. And
that soft tube is kind of stuck together with a level of viscosity. And then with the change in
pressure, that popping is that opening of the tube and that changes the pressure in your middle ear.
So I don't know if anybody has had the problem, like I have, going up at an airplane and your
ears don't pop because maybe you have a sinus infection that I'm prone to with my sinus issue.
And then it you have pressure on the used station tube because of inflammation. And then the used
station tubes can't open up and your ear feels like it's going to explode. A matter of fact, a person's
ear drum could explode. And that's the that's the shattering of your ear drum and then it's
going to take weeks or months to heal. So opening up your used station tube is an issue. So personally,
I cannot go in a hyperbaric chamber because I have difficulty regulating because of my
sinuses, the pressure in my middle ear. So for me, a hyperbaric chamber is out of the
pressure. I can't do it. It starts to hurt. I get paid in my ears, paid in my sinuses. I can't do
a hyperbaric chamber. If you've had issues with a hyperbaric chamber and or issues with point up at an
airplane for a couple of weeks, you have to get that new station tube to open. Now this used station tube
drains back into the way back of your throat.
I wish I could just show a camera on me trying to do it on myself, but it does elicit the gag reflex.
So if it's only on one side, how to open up the used station tube? And again, this is how you could
open up the used station tube if a person has a middle ear infection. So with children that have
a middle ear infection, I used to do this all the time with kids is you go back with children. I
used my pinky and go back really quick and stroke that area where the used station tube is going
back and emptying in the back of your throat. That back of your throat is called the fossa of
rosabular. So the rosabular fossa is in the way back of your throat and you will hit the back of your
throat and you will elicit a gag reflex. So just so you know when you go back way back there,
it's to the one side and then to the other side with your finger and as an adult doing it on
yourself, you're going to have to use your pointer finger, you're going way back in your throat and
stimulate the top. So if you're going back, you're going, you're going superior towards your head
and then to the left, if it's your left ear or to the right, if it's your right ear, and you just
stroke it quickly and you're going to start gagging and you're going to pull your finger back up.
That's how you would help open up the used station tube. You could also do it with gargling
with salt water. So gargling, the salt water can help stimulate the used station tube and have
stimulated to open up. So one time this happened to be when I was on an airplane, it took me two
weeks to get my used station tube to fully open up. Of course, if you're trying to yawd, you could hold
your nose and forcibly breathe out as hard as you can with your mouth closed so you're putting pressure
increasing the pressure in the back of your throat and try to force the used station tube open.
It's all about getting the used station tube open. That's what it's about. Taking some over the
counter anti-histamines can be helpful because over the counter anti-histamines can help open that up.
So even taking some Benadryl might be helpful. Again, I said, gargling with salt water, those are the
kind of things that you try to get the used station tube to open up with. Good question.